we're gonna begin with this a former
Democratic candidate for lieutenant
governor in Nevada has suddenly made Joe
Biden's all but certain presidential
campaign uncertain Lucy Florida says
Biden touched and kissed her in a way
that unsettled her during a campaign
event nearly five years ago now when he
was Barack Obama's Vice President Biden
is disputing Florida story while he
prepares to get into the 2020 race some
of his potential rivals for the
Democratic nomination said over the
weekend they believe Flores but it is
something voters would have to decide ed
O'Keefe looks at why the allegation
rings true for some of Biden's critics
heed good morning good morning John were
still weeks away from Biden's
anticipated entry into the presidential
race and the accusation made over the
weekend speaks to a part of his behavior
that some find harmless but that his
accuser says deserves more scrutiny she
tells CBS News she was too nervous to
share her story until now all of a
sudden I feel I feel hands on my
shoulders and and Vice President Joe
Biden is behind me lucy flores alleges
that joe biden approached her suddenly
from behind at a 2014 campaign event
when she was running for nevada
lieutenant governor he smelled my hair
and then he planted he leaned in further
and planted the slow kiss on the top of
my head flores originally made the
allegation in an essay published Friday
by the cut.com writing I had never
experienced anything so blatantly
inappropriate and unnerving before in a
statement Sunday Biden said in my many
years on the campaign trail and in
public life I have offered countless
handshakes hugs expressions of affection
support and comfort and not once never
did I believe I acted inappropriately we
have arrived at an important time when
women feel they can and should relate
their experiences and men should pay
attention and I will biden's known for a
personable some might say affectionate
campaign style that sometimes raises
eyebrows late Sunday Stephanie Carter
wife of former defense secretary ash
Carter defended Biden writing at the
moment he leaned in to speak with her at
her husband's 2015 swearing-in ceremony
has been misinterpreted the Joe Biden in
my picture is a close friend
helping someone get through a big day
for which I will always be grateful
Carter said Flores is a former supporter
of Bernie Sanders his 2016 presidential
campaign and she attended a rally for
candidate Beto O'Rourke over the weekend
she said she wants voters to consider
Biden's behavior
this is serious behavior and we should
talk about that and we should it we
shouldn't ignore it the organizer the
2014 campaign event in question says
he's reviewed more than 700 photographs
from that day and found nothing
resembling Florence's accusation she
told CBS News she felt violated and that
she doesn't believe Biden should run
some of his potential 20/20 opponents
say they're aware of the accusation but
wouldn't say whether this disqualifies
him from the race Nora all right
interesting to get all sides and all
points of view on that
Edie thank you so much